Bianca's gonna start off this hour in
California hi Bianca
welcome today Ramsey show how can
Anthony I help today hi guys thank you
so much for talking with me we
definitely need your advice my husband
and I are about to be done with baby
step three and in the middle of all this
mess doesn't it yes it does it feels
wonderful great timing we have three big
live babies we want to accomplish and we
don't know where to start or what to put
first so we have four kids currently who
are all going to be in college soon one
is already in her first year in college
and the other three are triplets who are
all going to be in college in about two
years
yeah we also want to have another baby
but we need to move out of the house
we're living in to do that we're 32 and
44 so the sooner the better and the
third thing is we want to move on to the
baby step 3b and save a down payment for
a house we live in the Bay Area and a
modest house in our area like a
three-bedroom house is five to six
hundred thousand dollars we don't know
what is the home here living in worth we
rented a really really old house we have
great rent because my husband's been
here for a long time so to move to the
same type of house in our neighborhood
would be $1,500 more per month so we've
you stayed here even though it's a
really old house okay you're 32 mm-hmm
when you're 42 if you could only have
done one of these three things what
would it be I would like to have another
baby okay
well the good news is there's plenty of
room in this rental house because the
restaurants leaving for college that's
funny
they're coming though right I mean it's
good there's gonna be okay I mean one's
already gone right yeah okay so there's
room opening up everyday you know and
so and if I'm you my second one is I
want these kids these older kids to go
to school debt-free yes right and then
my third goal be by house yeah okay if
it was me I would have had that that
would be my order but you get to decide
your order I don't care it's your order
but here's the thing when you try to do
everything at once and you justify it
emotionally you're gonna bout to go into
debt for one of them or two of them or
all three of them because everything you
mentioned is as has a nobility to it
home ownership college education new
babies so on so the ones going to school
are not yours no they're my stepchildren
okay all right I suddenly did the math
and it just occurred to me you didn't
have them when you were in well okay
hopefully yeah all right so all right
good so I mean that makes it a little
harder a tiny little bit harder for you
how long have you been there stepmom
married for two years and we've been
together six years okay all right so two
years though you've been super heavily
invested and so they're your children
you love them you care about them but it
you know some of these other things are
probably if if I if a normal human we're
doing this they they you know you having
your own child that they you get
pregnant and you deliver the baby is a
huge priority to you maybe more than his
kids going to college kind of thing yeah
that makes sense by the way that's what
I would do that's how I would be
thinking and it doesn't mean you don't
care about them and it doesn't mean
you're not putting them ahead of your
own once or you're being selfish or
something like that that was not what I
was saying yeah but um here's the thing
you can do anything if you line it up
and say I'm not doing the other one
until I can do the other one and you
just say that means you're probably not
buying this house for maybe five six
years
okay and my husband really wants a house
that's his like pride and joy he feels
really badly about himself that we live
in such a you know kind of crappy place
that's mine I mean he can he can want
that but my only question then is like I
said before Anthony yeah what do you
want more exactly well what are the
priorities you know for both of you well
I would sit down and have a conversation
and say Bay this is where I met and like
him to say babe where this is where I
met and something that Dave said earlier
on in the show he said both of you all
gotta have peace and I gotta agree with
it and here's what I would do if I was
married I would actually once we come to
peace with whatever that is we're gonna
write it down yep all right this is
number one then this is number two then
this is number three so this way we're
not being distracted by other things
we're going down that priority list but
as a single man that would be my
suggestion just to get the priorities
written down and both of you all be at
peace with it
yeah that's good because I tell you we
had an argument one time it wasn't
nearly as noble as what you're doing my
wife had been driving on those old blue
Astro vans you remember those two-tone
blue s program I do
trashy thing yes and she's been driving
that thing he had 800,000 miles on it
felt like and I needed to do some stuff
at the office and she wanted to upgrade
the car to a better used car we had
argument about which one went first and
as we talked about it she was actually
right she did she needed to move up out
that crappy car we did that first then
we did the office thing there you go you
doing both just which order yes